خدمت وخدمته وخدمته قال انت ما تعرف شيء
وقال كلمه قويه ما تنقل صراحه
كلمه جدا جدا جدا نرفزني
[موسيقى]
عبد العزيز سعد القحطاني ومشرف خدمات
عملاء اعمل منذ 24 سنه استمريت على الوضع
هذا فاعجبني الوضع لين تطورت وصرت مشرف
خدمات امانه
[موسيقى]
انه نوصف كل الفئات ما ندري من الشخص هذا
من الشخص هذا ما ندري فيجونا ناس يعني
يجلسون بالشهر بشهرين على طول هذا ما يكمل
فتره التجربه اننا همم نقول لها تفضل انت
صالح العمل غيابك اربع ايام تاخير اكثر من
خمسه ايام عندك اربع مكالمات او ست
مكالمات مقفل في وجه امين او زي كذا انت
في مجال كول سنتر الكول سنتر انه يكون
الشخص اللي يخدم الامير النفاهم الوضع مني
انت فاهم الامين لان الاهميه
[موسيقى]
يؤثر على الشركه
اثنين شباب جالسين اول ما دخلت نفس
الموضوع زي ما تقول زي شخصيه مقويه
وفاهمين الوضع قال اسمعي اذا صار لك شيء
ولا في مكالمه عندك زي كذا ولا في زي غزل
او زي كده
بدايات يعني
حلوه
كلها وين الشريط يعني
ولا شيء
اول مره اسمع صوتك
[موسيقى]
تعال سحب الاسم مكالمه سحب العميل هذه
تبغى رقم مثلا هرفي
فانا رحت له دخلت عليه
[موسيقى]
ما سويت شيء وين الشريط
الله يرحمه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
في الليل
طريقه تزعج الموظفين في اسحبها انا يمكن
نص ساعه زي كذا الوضع كده صار يوميا
باستمرار كده
طولوا وصار عندنا ما نبغاه نحن نرفع رقمه
الى الجوده لانهم يمنعون الرقم هذا انه
يتصل على الرقم هذا اللي عندنا الموحد
في بعض الجمل
هذه ضروريه لان ايش نحاول نوصل لشمونه
تنشيط نفس الجوال نفس الشريحه او تنشيط
الشيء هذا لا بد ان احنا نشطه بس لا بدنا
ندخل الجهاز علشان يشبك على اخر درج كان
موجود فيه يعني احيانا البرج يكون شابك
فيه اللي هو في النرجس مثلا
قد قال لشخص
يرفزني صراحه قبل قديم طبعا كان شخص مره
قاسيه علي فقال لي عطني اسمك فرح عطيته
عبد العزيز
عبد العزيز مدري ايش قبيله ثانيه وجد شكوى
سبحان الله المدير
[موسيقى]
مصر مصر
مشاكل
[موسيقى]
غير طبيعي
اتصل عليه واحد من جيران كان يمزح معي هو
زي كذا
فسال قال
هذا في بدايه الامر طبعا ايام اول فكان
مهدي ابو السفاره الامريكيه رقمها فانا
تلقفت قلت له ايش تبغى
[موسيقى]
قال والله بتجيب لي عامل المخيم
والرجال ضحك وعرفني انا ما عرفتك في عصر
رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي اساس
النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي نوظف
خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه سلوشن سبايسي
[موسيقى]
اشياء كثيره خدمه العملاء انا والله
احيانا اطلع ما ادري وين سيارتي
موقف سيارتي والله ما ادري الضغوطات هذه
كلها تسير لك احيانا من الموظفين من
العملاء من البرامج اللي عندك من الاداء
من شغلك من الايميلات اللي تشوفها من كم
هذه تشوفه تطلع انت تعبان خدمات جدا
[موسيقى]
ههه
والله بشيل الهدف ما عرفتكم والله انا كنت
متخوف وانا كنت بنحاش بس ههه عبد الملك
اللي كان ناويني قال لو تجوا شفت ما شاء
الله حريص
سيتم تسجيل المكالمه
[موسيقى]